did you know that Michael Jordan had a
very specific request when it came to
making the movie Air including who could
play what characters when it came to
making this film there's also a major
reason why Michael Jordan's character
wasn't really in the movie plus a super
abnormal way every scene was written
that only these incredible actors could
get through on time there's a lot to
unpack
you might recognize the actor who plays
her none other than the iconic Viola
Davis this was one thing that was really
important to Michael Jordan when it came
to creating this film Viola had to be
the one to play his mother obviously she
was thrilled to be hand-picked for the
role if you've ever seen videos of
Dolores Jordan she's extraordinary but
she was also incredibly nervous even
though she's one of the few people in
the world who holds an egot an Emmy a
Grammy an Oscar and a Tony that's an
enormous responsibility that plays
someone who's real someone that you know
is tangible and like it also helps that
Michael Jordan is a huge fan of hers
someone's going to be my mother in the
movie it's going to be the best actor in
the world so yeah obviously no one had
an issue with Michael's request to cast
her except of course Ben Affleck's
initial worry that he couldn't get her
on the film apparently Viola Davis only
met Michael Jordan briefly one time
outside of a hotel she was staying at he
said oh man my wife and mom
mother-in-law they love how to get away
with murder she clearly made a lasting
impression that was my only contact with
Michael Jordan This was another request
Michael Jordan made in order for the
movie to have his Blessing Howard white
absolutely had to be in the movie and if
you don't know who he is he's the vice
president of Michael Jordan's shoe brand
Ben Affleck who directed the film took
this as an opportunity to cast Chris
Tucker as he wanted to work with him and
hadn't been able to for a while
for Ben Affleck this movie was like a
casting dream come true especially
because this was the first movie ever
produced by his production company big
moves another big decision that was made
for this movie was not showing Michael
Jordan in any of the scenes I don't
think anybody is good enough to create
an environment where you can show
somebody go and Michael Jordan they just
thought Michael was too much of an icon
to try and recreate in a movie they
thought it would bring everyone out of
the film and essentially lose the
progress they made on creating the world
they were trying to show what I loved
about it was he exists in the movie kind
of in the way he exists in the
consciousness of the world he's always
talked about in the movie but never
shown something Ben Affleck really loves
is that it's a film that you think is
going to be about Michael Jordan but you
find out it's about somebody else
instead so another thing Ben Affleck
really loves about this movie is that he
like gets to spend time with his buddy
Matt Damon
oh stop rushing me back stop crowding
the plane they've been friends for like
40 something years now and like I
mentioned before opened this production
company together that was always the
goal from the jump why aren't we hanging
out and spending more time together
since we managed to stay friends this
whole time and like they've never had a
better time since they've started
working on movies together these guys
literally have an unspoken language I
loved coming to work every day I love
seeing that I loved first of all he's a
genius Ben Affleck says this movie was
the best work experience of his entire
life because it never once felt like
work another reason this movie was so
huge was because it was Ben Affleck's
first time directing well technically I
mean we did a high school
is where he was like listen to I think
you should do it like this apparently
he's been directing Matt Damon for 40
something years actually though it
wasn't that crazy of a transition
because they've been writing acting and
producing together for all these years
the transition into directing felt very
natural and it was something he was
waiting to get into more professionally
for a long time coming this movie was
also the perfect origin point for their
production company Ben Affleck
originally received the script and like
obviously loved it when he showed it to
Matt Damon he brought it to his
attention because he thought the movie
aligned with everything their company
represented knowing your worth and
respect and taking risks risk the only
thing Ben didn't approve of upon reading
it was that there was actually no
African-American people in the original
script I know that's actually pretty
crazy this is what led to his
conversation with Michael Jordan and the
specific requests and character changes
I'm gonna make sure that if I do make
this movie whatever is important to
Michael Jordan be included in this story
and speaking of requests let's loop back
around and talk about Michael Jordan's
request for his father's character he
said my dad had the best personality
I've ever known I said and we got the
right guy that guy is Julius tennan
Viola Davis's husband everyone on set
really took to him apparently he's the
coolest most hilarious guy you could
ever meet
everybody loves him I'm like Viola Davis
also loves working with her husband
exactly who we are is where what we are
in private we are fun we laugh all the
time Julius was also super stoked to see
his name in the reviews he's like he has
been a long time since someone mentioned
me in a review so this movie has a ton
of abnormally long scenes I'm talking
five six and seven page scenes for those
of you who aren't familiar with
screenplays even a two-page scene is
considered long so this movie was chock
full of scenes that should have made the
shooting days incredibly long but
because of how talented and professional
these actors were they were able to get
everything done in a surprisingly short
amount of time we budgeted 33 days we
were done in 24 days and we couldn't we
couldn't slow down this is actually an
astoundingly short amount of time to get
a movie done especially with scenes of
this caliber and like that says a lot
about the level of Talent on set I woke
up every day and went to work and was
opposite a hero of mine he said they
would often get everything done a little
earlier than intended and they'd have to
scramble to figure out what they were
gonna do next so while we're talking
about heroes Peter Moore has some tough
shoes to fill the shoe designer played
by Matthew Mayer actually passed away
about a week before the role was given
to him so he had to look for outside
sources to craft his on-screen character
how do you describe getting to the mind
of somebody who's so good at what they
do he ended up watching a ton of
documentaries and footage on Peter to
try and get into his head but he
ultimately found the experience and
let's be real pretty boring he said
listening to someone talk about their
craft isn't as interesting as you would
think it is at the end of the day he
concluded that Peter Moore was just a
guy a guy who was really really good at
Shoe designing and decided to keep his
character more specific to the pages of
the script rather than his real life
personality she ever noticed there's
always a big speech in a sports movie
there was a lot of pressure for Ben and
Matt they were writing this speech well
after the movie was done shooting they
ended up re-recording some of it in ADR
and they really wanted to capture the
essence of the film and the fact that
this responsibility isn't all it's
cracked up to be but also the fact that
everyone was hearing something
completely different the only person who
really hears the core of the speech is
of course Michael's mother it's not all
gonna be great like this is a burden
that's being put on myself again the
emphasis in the movie is not on Michael
but on his mother and the experiences of
all the other characters around him so
this big speech is constructed a little
bit differently than your average sports
movie speech and there was a lot of
pressure behind the scenes to get it
right
air is definitely not your typical
sports movie from Michael Jordan being a
backseat director Viola Davis filling
the enormous shoes of his mother and
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck bringing
their Bromance Vibes to the set I'm
still kind of reeling what was your
favorite behind the scenes moment